what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are gonna watch
Wednesday episode six today almost done
with the series John how does that make
you feel I am filled with whoa I'm not
ready to let go how are you sir I did
not watch a bunch of Jenna Ortega
interviews last night what are you
talking about anyway guys listen you
know what would help us out right now if
you guys can leave a like I know you
can't it doesn't cost you a dime but it
sure does help us out so please go ahead
and do that also subscribe click that
notification Bell get notified what our
next reaction for Wednesday is up here
on the channel and as always as we
constantly mention full-length Reaction
watch along is where you sync up with
your own copy of Wednesday available for
super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page become a super sexy reject today to
check out all the exclusive shows that
we cover over there with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
alrighty on to this episode
foreign
I don't hold seances very often but my
mother told me goodie is the only one
that can train me to control my psychic
ability she doesn't really warned you
about her sooner I cracked this case
[Music]
the most Tim Burton Ouija board
where's Enid
I was like she's gonna stop her here I
was reaching into the black maw death to
contact a relative and attempting to
summon her but she seems to be ignoring
mind treaties you thought about using
one of my scented candles the aroma of
steak tartar is to die for
oh my
meaty candle maybe good answer to you
after all I doubt she communicates in
magazine cutouts you don't know that
the game is afoot
if you are Justice please do not lie
foreign
you insisted on coming along
I was fine on my own don't be a pussycat
why do I just stay out here
look out
you got the zenid you're the muscle
looks dangerous outside too
added a sound effect to her turning
around
[Music]
sound effect does not match that's what
all flashlights sound like come on man
whoever you are show yourself
[Music]
try anything and you'll lose limbs
oh surprise
oh no
[Music]
happy birthday to you how'd they know
thing oh
happy birthday
to you I should have known you were
behind this
I thought my cake design was pretty
inspired
the pink balloon was my little touch why
don't you make a wish
come on Wednesday
Wish For answers fire will rain
when I Rise the first part of that
phrase was burned on a Nevermore song
it can't be a coincidence
we never eaten that cake are we cake
would have to wait
[Music]
nice hot headshot I was told you could
teach me how to control my ability there
is no controlling a raging River you
must learn to navigate it without
drowning time is not on our side they
don't look exactly the same to me but
they are at the same actually yeah
they must do something to make her look
more gaunt that were Raven is a solitary
one the balloon unable to trust others
only seeing the darkness within them is
that supposed to scare me it should you
have to be crazy not to be scared may
your 16th be a sour and misery felt as
your desire your ever doubting mother
and father
the last thing to hide it before they
left on parents weekend
wow we're still accepting presents
oh what did you get her a bright pink
Blazer what is it exactly
silly I
signature colors
I have one too no twinsies wear them
together to class
Lucas feels terrible about what happened
at the dance but he had nothing to do
with burning those words onto your lawn
you don't know that
he does his community service here and
we forget it ever happened community
service here yes
last night in the Crypt you had another
Vision didn't you what'd you see you
said I was ready to speak with you
you still think I'm the monster haven't
rolled it out
you want my help you know where to find
me
Wednesday Adams Falls in your court
Wednesday that's a friend
[Laughter]
the ball of playtonic connection is in
your court
where'd you get that
the bracelet this woman in the next
Booth told me about this self-help app
so he could help me refocus my life
Morning song
I wonder if there's a well-placed you in
there the more you listen to them the
more they think they're closing to you
how do you know
I just do
which is why I'm warning the Normie
idiot who ruined my killer dress with
his prank to not get sucked into Morning
song Lucas is acting like she's flirting
with him yeah I know then again he
always acts that way
my parents always made sure my birthdays
were memorable
let's go
perfect surprise
[Music]
oh cool the perfect cake
oh that's awesome someone's gonna make
that for real the perfect party games oh
she had a bunch of friends
[Applause]
oh
yes
[Music]
that is creepy I haven't seen you since
our session with your family which was
certainly one I won't forget
I'll leave you to it
who's goody
she's a very distant cousin sounds like
she doesn't see you for who you really
are she sees more than you know who are
you therapist I doubt a cold heartless
person would be sitting by her friend's
bedside feeling some modicum of guilt
for his condition I didn't ask for a
free session consider it my birthday
gift
one of my therapists have used that line
kill Eugene to prove your point
do you feel guilty now
an old death certificate clusters
[Music]
Laurel Gates
if I asked you out to a non-birthday
song free dinner
would that be something you're
interested in
I have a tight deadline God damn it
term paper it's about how whitewashing
the sins of our past will come back to
kill us all thank you
oh timely oh
okay did I do something I feel like ever
since the Raven you've kind of been
ghosting me I love that shot it's such a
distance between them now nah but
ghosting is romantic in this contest she
got closer to you man pushes you away
now that burned onto the lawn at school
it's also etched on the wall inside
crack Stones correct
all right well I'll make sure I put out
an APB in a dead pilgrim I figured since
you no longer have an old Vendetta to
obsess over you're free to solve some
real crime
I don't bury hatchets
what a waste I sharpen them nice
your line Works a little shaky
I saw that in a vision do you recognize
it
ooh good perspective work I pass it when
I go honey
happy birthday
after the dance I just wanted to forget
about you but I couldn't so I started
painting and that's what came out all
right
I can hear you up there playing
nice effect created Netflix
I'll buy one
[Music]
music of your soul Wednesday now you
look a little moved by that Wednesday
Adams Wednesday forgot this could you
give it back to her
birthday gift from Enid
aren't you your boyfriend go
definitely not no problem
I was just leaving anyway
until no Mr smiles
take your advice
it's on the other wrist
it's on my ankle most people think I'll
never amount to anything and while we're
being honest I haven't done much to make
them think differently
why'd you trash the dance I don't know
guess I was angry that my dad was
humiliated on Outreach day
I pay back but then after we did it kind
of felt like crap I realized I needed to
wipe the board you know start over if
that makes any sense
it's a lot of sense it's wise
goody showed me this house for a reason
I need to unlock its Secrets or die
trying Wednesday Adams Psychic Detective
medium
sure
Simon Baker will be here any moment
or uh Patricia Arquette I don't know
so you have something to do with that
there death
I need a distraction
I know just appear
we will be spooked
it's a long shot so I'm gonna have to
lay it out for you
we'll do it over pie at the weatherbane
you are so quiet oh my God are you gonna
can't fear of this come on max
spooky
what
their meaning
[Music]
damn who hit him
oh
jeez
call 9-1-1
[Music]
what we do in the back of the mayor's
SUV I saw him coming out of the Gates
mansion Gates mansion
the hell were you doing house hunting
when someone is run over on the way to
give the police key information it
usually means they were onto something
and all signs point to the Kate's family
in that house how they're all dead every
last one and I don't believe in ghosts
maybe you should and I believe in ghost
series I've seen the crazy [ __ ] around
the corner yeah you know what school is
nearby I draw the line after werewolves
and vampires
as of now the school is on Full lockdown
and your off-campus privileges are
revoked until further notice it's fine
she barely goes to school anyway
are you all right I I can't imagine
witnessing something like that it was on
my bucket list
[Laughter]
no man chooses evil because it is evil
he only mistakes it for happiness the
good he seeks
did she put you up to this
encourage me to pursue other interests
no
but she will expel you if you continue
to defy her so you're only looking out
for my best interests always
I think we're a lot alike we aren't uh I
already have a mother and a therapist
that's enough torture even for me oh
I would like to know where you get your
clothes though she's just been pushing
everyone away this episode except for
Xavier
I've reconsidered your offer the
non-birthday dinner that's great um pick
me up at 7
get in loser we're going mystery solving
steer clear Wednesday Adam she's kind of
girl is going to get you hurt
leave me another type is that supposed
to be about Mom
of course not and that would require you
to actually talk about her
I can't deal with this right now oh of
course not close did you ever even love
her
every scene window is about Mom we gotta
talk about Mom but we're not gonna talk
about mom
if only there were a way for us to get
off campus and have a little birthday
redo
two best friends
too bad the school is on lockdown what
how about I say I'm about to Wolf out
and get a pass to the Lupine cages and
so you volunteered to lock me in
my deviousness has finally rubbed off on
you what a great idea
I want that Rubik's Cube
I gotta be a million on Etsy right now
[Music]
well done here for my date he's our Uber
driver Uber driver I thought we were
going on a date I thought this was a
girls night out just been a change of
plans okay what's up with the weird
matching hoodie scarf things don't ask
it's a snood man
what does she think
she's on her table Tyler
I want to do this and you should have
just said so you didn't have to trick us
if you want to go you can
are you totally manipulated them
let me try
[Laughter]
it's pointless
can I try
yeah
hey you're not such a late bloomer after
all extra werewolf strength
the caddy oh my God
the car that hit the mayor
dark turn
to just now well someone's clearly
occupying it
thing would really come in handy right
about now
thing is not necessary
[Music]
worshipers blood will rain blood will
rain
[Music]
one of those was freshly extinguished
crack Stone will return you're still
warm
all right Tyler you check the rest of
the ground floor in a deny will search
upstairs I don't think you guys should
split up
[Music]
let's go time Tyler Hulk out come on his
eyes look like the Monster's eyes yeah
Wednesday we need to see this
look how clean this room is
that's me
no duster cobwebs
I was gonna say is the doctor like
secretly their daughter ah
ah
okay
looks like somebody moved back into
their old room she died 25 years ago
drowned overseas
[Music]
a likely story
[Music]
[Music]
it's actually kind of scary yeah
gotta get this thing moving
some strong wool
oh yikes
I might have left is some important
information actually yeah what is this
the family morgue
kind of
the foot hey
the half of head where are those extra
toes
[Music]
[Music]
ooh this is exciting evidence
[Music]
where was Tyler this whole time you know
he shouted
[Music]
where'd you come from uh I'm just here
for a mislead oh my God is the therapist
the monster no I will you cannot believe
her now
I will I will go down swinging die on
this hill
I'm okay Sheriff I understand you're
upset but I think you need to see
something
that's all taken away damn it
comes in handy oh it's all gone now
somebody cleared this place out after we
left
today I told you signs pointed to this
to this right is that your justification
for almost getting my son and your
friends killed you're my new Grudge on
Wednesday yeah
you are forbidden from seeing Tyler and
you are forbidden from pursuing anything
to do with this case understood give me
your gun and your badge you're directly
violated my explicit order and left
Compass during a lockdown
I think Contrition might be an order
right now miss Adams not hubris I'll
never apologize for trying to uncover a
truth as well you shouldn't
what is this
it's a warning from Rowan is this why he
tried to kill you
his mother drew it before she died
said I was destined to destroy the
school
well then we have to kill you Wednesday
now you know what's at stake everything
you've had to protect no less
I think I deserve another chance
[Music]
please
Wednesday the hero one more step out of
line and you will be expelled
no ifs or no buts Enid and save your
spirit as well no more negotiation
she's not Morticia
it's more like Gomez where are you going
yoko's room
Thornhill said I can't crash there for a
few nights oh tonight was just the icing
on the birthday cake you couldn't even
be bothered to cut you will use anyone
to get what you want even if it means
putting them in danger
we could have died tonight because of
your stupid Obsession but we didn't
Dart Detective
always put myself out there
thought of your feelings told people I
know she gives off serial killer Vibes
but she's really just shy I never asked
you to do that you didn't have to
because that's what friends do
you want to be alone Wednesday be alone
Dark Night of the soul and accompanying
Thunderclap a gnawing feeling
[Music]
foreign
watching me
[Music]
oh [ __ ] damn
oh my God I found someone's Pi pics we
all seem to be connected like a spider's
web and when mayor Walker got too close
to the truth
he was silenced
no Take that Mary Shelley
[Music]
I will find you badass
and I will kill you great transition
ah we're back to form yes yeah
absolutely we're back to the momentum
that was great that was that was great
will not sway It's gotta be Tyler it has
to be but her eyes he's got his hairdo
in the eyes of the therapist look like
the uh more of the eyes of the monster
it's fair it could be
that's a really good theory
that you brought up but now I'm gonna
stick to that I'm gonna make sure to cut
it out of the reaction yes please yeah I
deserve that I'm not gonna let you get
the credit for that don't worry don't
worry it'll only last for now when it
turns out to be Tyler then you can rub
it in my face that's that's a really
good theory that it's that it's Laurel
what was her name Laurel Gates canbot or
oh yeah or yeah Laura Laura Gates Laura
Gates is uh the therapist really
I mean that I could certainly see I feel
like that there they they did a thing
with the roses and it like the first
when she's in the hospital room they
pause on the roses and like some about
those Roses
and then uh they're the same color at
least and kind of withery style that
they find in the bedroom yes
I don't know yes maybe we're both right
about different things
idea of a good mystery supposed to throw
you off
to make you doubt your suspicions sure
and whenever I do that and if I sway
from it I'm like I should have stuck to
my guns
I mean would it be too much though if
she's both Laurel Gades and the monster
but why would Tyler the monster why
would he have the scratches
unless he's doing like like I gotta
cover this up or something like like the
way that series under this yes we will
use that yeah yeah yeah because it's
like he calls from downstairs to warn
them that he's about to Hulk out we
don't know why he hulks out or what
causes it and then yeah as he's turning
back he's like okay I gotta do a quick
Rippy I could see that although I'm also
like what does he do with his clothes
because he's not wearing all of his full
outfit when he hulks out so then did he
like put his shirt back on and did he
have like a remaining claw to go or did
he just find something else to cut
himself up with I don't know Sam can be
said for Xavier sure definitely not
Xavier it's not it's not Xavier you
weren't misled by that mislead about
Xavier showing up just at the right time
can't be
uh nah nah I can't be man is too well
motivated by thing so
yeah I think I don't know stick to your
guns G stick to your guns and this will
stick into this will be the exceptions
I think you're right though about Laurel
gay that sounds like a very solid Theory
that sounds remarkably solid yeah okay
okay
well both got a hill to die on
skill declaring this since the first
episode yeah your Hill is much bigger I
will die on an adjacent Mound
I gotta stick to it
um well the first uh yeah I thought I
thought this was a really
I just left the I love the vibe of this
episode it was so dark it felt so
noir-ish and but still like No warish
And Gothic at the same time it had a
great blend of both and this is my
favorite of the mystery angle of this
whole season like the mystery of foot
and trying to solve it and then it was
the most intense it's ever gotten like
that was really when the monster was
coming in and the way they it felt like
an actual monster as this show has had
like a monster here and creatures there
and that was the first sequence that
felt like a monster movie yeah and so it
was incredibly effective and it was
suspenseful and it was exciting like it
was a fun perilous like like a
family-friendly version of those
perilous monster movies and I really
enjoyed the vibe of that and uh it felt
most
in some ways this show kind of feels
like
uh if Adam's Family took place in a
world that was like Hogwarts meet
stranger things and yeah I think that
was a big vibe that I had there the
whole time which is like a lot of that
stranger things spooky Vibe uh
throughout and also the enhancement of
the because the last episode would have
you sort of believe that Wednesday was
on a path to you know opening up being
more vulnerable connecting but it seems
that she has now closed herself off even
more which in a lot of ways is more
human once you get to that path of oh
I'm starting to connect I'm sorry now
you retreat
but obviously that is supported by the
the oh so if I'm forgetting exactly what
goody Adams told her at the beginning
other than the fact that she's destined
to be alone and I feel like that plays a
fact in her emotional motives this
episode she said some other [ __ ] yeah I
don't remember what she said yeah about
the path of the Raven it was a lot about
the path of the Raven and all that and
that
had to do with her Visions damn
because yeah there's like so much
happening and it is like so early on in
the episode and two I was just getting
lost in like the nuances of like oh I
like the subtle accent she does and
things like that but but yeah I mean
she's at least leading her to the truth
that's at the gates house she gives her
that that clue basically the Gates house
is where you need to go
well yeah I thought this was a really I
thought and I thought it enhanced a lot
of the the supernatural Aura and the
Mystery Aura
um like the The Ether of it
was quite powerful both throughout and
uh like this is mainly like a nighttime
episode
and very investigative so yeah I enjoyed
this one a lot this was great like this
was uh back to the momentum that I was
hoping the show would pick back up again
and it did after one episode so yeah
yeah love it now Sheriff's son's gonna
have a massive Vendetta next episode
he's gonna have a whole character
re-change he's gonna not smile anymore
it was insanely manipulative what she
did it
truly yeah it's very very manipulative
yeah yeah absolutely I would be mad but
I like I like the characters of
of like I'm gonna do whatever it takes
to get Justice and nothing will get in
my way or do the right thing to be the
hero and but it's like costing her so
much and she doesn't realize how much
like they've they've morphed her into a
detective yeah that's her character she
is she is like an award detective
Wednesday at a private eye like I don't
care about people but she really does
and um it's bothered by that and it's
fine so I think it's a really good
balance of it yeah it's the hidden
duality of like yeah you want to solve
the mystery and take down the evil but
why are you doing that you're also doing
that because there are people who don't
deserve to be subject to that and some
of whom you can now point to is like
yeah these are people that I would want
to save from Peril even if it's not at
the Forefront of why she's doing all
this it's in there yeah yeah yeah yeah
and and yeah just like nobody's weight
like even in even characters who show up
briefly like nobody's wasted like that
scene on the staircase with Gwendolyn
Christie's like the one principal Weems
major scene and like I thought that was
great like it's just the way that they
orchestrated everything and like you
know these well-worn tropes of like you
know oh you can't sneak out after dark
and of course that's exactly what we got
to do but yeah I thought they they had
like the perfect blend of tension and
fun and then when the actual like scary
stuff starts to happen like it lulls you
into focusing so much on the clues that
that stuff does kind of burst in and
take you by surprise and it doesn't seem
villainous
good one Gwendolyn Christy I'm yeah I'm
really curious because yeah like at the
outset you are so kind of there are
various reasons where on the surface you
would just imagine that she is like
directly a villain of some sort and I
feel like there's a they might do
something interesting where it is yeah
like she is certainly willing to go to
extreme lengths to protect the greater
good but I think that's a more fitting
Nuance of the hero now is yeah evildoers
don't necessarily think they're doing
evil obviously and yeah principal Weems
is in a weird position so I could see
how she could come out of this as a very
gray character with maybe that I hate
you but damn it I respect you kind of
vibe at the end and and that's the thing
is because you have the Tyler debate
about whether or not he'll be the
monster I feel like there are they've
done well to cast so many other shadows
and so many other little Mysteries that
even if certain things read a little bit
obvious it it's doesn't take any of the
Wind out of the sale for me because
there are things like that where I'm
like I don't know I don't know I feel
like principal Williams could have
easily been behind the wheel of the
Cadillac maybe she is involved at the
gates house or maybe she is as she
appears and that whole like that scene
where she tells Wednesday she cops two
impersonating
um uh Rowan I was like I kind of bought
that in the moment which is a good
mislead if it's a mislead but she was
like yeah you know we didn't want to you
know tarnish his memory we didn't want
to bring any heat to the school I was
like sure I buy that so I could see her
turning out not totally terrible
the whole thing I don't know other than
a good job they've done a really good
job here yeah and just when Sheriff
Hopper and her were signing it along I
was about to adopt a letter
God damn it it's okay yeah I was gonna
say now we gotta figure out which
stranger things kid every character is
and they all wanted to they try to throw
her birthday party I know and even Ajax
and a few other people showed no there
were people who showed up who I didn't
think would give your [ __ ] to show up I
didn't realize it was a friendship five
or six people are here that's all you
guys kind of gave [ __ ] about her that's
kind of funny yeah and even Bianca
wasn't completely like you know she
could have easily been very [ __ ] about
bringing this nude back but she was just
like yeah sure I'll bring it back I know
they Justified their relationship her
and Lucas but
I don't still fully buy it
um yeah I'm curious I find Luke is
charming but he's just all smiles up
until this point and I feel like uh I I
don't know I like I like the idea of the
character I am enjoying watching him but
I'm not fully I get where they landed
and why they landed there I guess it was
what started up that engine that I
didn't quite buy like their first scene
together like what is happening here
like this I'm not buying this scene I
bought the latter scene more but the
first scene of what got them there that
that emotionally I don't know I I again
I guess it has something to do with the
fact that he had the brakes didn't want
her to protect him or something is that
the first real conversation they've had
that is right
because I know you know I mean post post
the dance does he do they talk at all
today I'm trying to think like it it
might have I don't remember
significantly any major not that it had
to be like a huge scene but like a a
thing setting up that they might have
some kind of Rapport to build on in the
future or some kind of knowledge of each
other other than like oh yeah you're the
sheriff's son and oh yeah you go to
Nevermore
um so yeah I feel like that could have
maybe been fleshed by that orb if
they're both black actors they're both
black actors it's true they have to have
a connection like pair them up yep
Oh you mean that's why they do things
no I yeah I mean maybe if he again I
don't want to slag the performance
because I do find it Charming but maybe
if there had been in that scene a little
bit more like he's just so charming and
so kind of like even when he's doing the
prank because he's auditioning the whole
time I like Bianca a lot I just like I
think I feel like he's auditioning a lot
I feel like he's auditioning a lot and
there's something about his attitude
that I just don't a hundred percent feel
the commitment to I liked it in the
later scene where he's like yeah I don't
really know why I did it uh even and and
extrapolating on that but in the moment
when he's being a bully I'm like I don't
really believe this guy's an actual
bully
like he just happens to kind of be
plopped here among these other
characters who do seem like actual
bullies and even though there are themes
you can draw about like yeah that's not
who he is he's being drawn into this
lifestyle it's not really well supported
by the characterization thus far yes
but uh we'll see he'll turn into
something very significant
all right let it play out
a player all right guys what did you
think about this episode leave your
thoughts down below
what's your favorite Jenna Ortega
interview tell us tell us tell us tell
us
you can leave a like subscribe
and let's send this for the patreon
Ricardo Martinez Adams Family you know
they got some some Latin roots so I
figure this would be the perfect time to
shout you out I wonder if you're a
spooky one in episode seven
uh you know because uh that's all right
dude I got a very big reason as to why
it's not episode seven I'm sorry I I
would have saved you for that but I got
big plans all right big plans to sit in
motion Ricardo Martinez in fact if you
want to get on the ground floor hit me
up we'll discuss it and then you can be
part of my master plan I will use you
much like Wednesday used her friends in
this episode for my own personal gain
and the gain of the greater good of the
patreon but at your expense Ricardo
so for the meantime until that happens I
hope you're having a good 2023 and uh
thank you for remaining with us through
all these wild and crazy shout outs we
love you and we appreciate you and we'll
see you next time much love
share away it's all episode stuff I
should have waited I'm sorry Ricardo
don't don't play it
[Music]